[Applause]
good evening everyone can you all hear
me okay y great well hello and welcome
to Intelligence Squared I'm Josh glancy
as you know and I'm delighted to welcome
alist Campbell here tonight he doesn't
really need a lot of introduction but
I'll give him one anyway um as I'm sure
you all know aliser was from 1994 to 200
three he was Tony Blair's spokesperson
Chief spokesperson and then director of
communications during the new labor
years uh he's also a leading advocate in
the field of mental health he's a
prolific author uh and most recently uh
he's co-presenter of is it the most
successful political podcast in Britain
after the news agents it's the most
successful political podcast in
Britain the rest is politics which he
obviously presents with Rory Stewart um
as I said alist has written a lot of
books uh including um a fairly
comprehensive account of the Blair years
which I'm sure you've all read um and
his latest book but what can I do was a
number one Sunday Times
bestseller and it's really a sort of I
suppose it's a kind of creed Aur for
what's gone wrong in British politics
but it also attempts to be quite
constructive about what what can be done
so um very pleased to welcome you here
alist and obviously this is a sort of
quite opportune moment to have a chat
about everything really there's a lot
going on in the world this is a very
political year ahead of us um so before
we start I would just you know
acknowledge there's been some quite
remarkable breaking news tonight with um
the announcement that the King King
Charles has cancer um obviously I don't
really want to speculate too much about
that or what will happen next but it did
strike me alist that there's an
openness in terms of how the Buckingham
Palace and the king have approached this
news uh and and other health issues he's
had recently that is perhaps different
to how we might have approached it in
the
past I think I think it's been very
deliberate and to be welcomed I think I
mean it's always a very difficult
balance to engage with any se you know
senior public
figures um when there are health issues
how much or how little you
say um and I think the historically any
people in positions of authority the
Instinct has been to to conceal for as
long as you can before you actually
admit as it were um I thought it was
interesting for example that when they
announced when he went into Hospital
recently and they announced the reason
namely this enlarged prostate that the
number of middle-aged and older men who
went and checked out their prostate went
stratospherically through the roof so it
is a very strange form of soft power um
that that that him making that the
palace making that announcement so look
as you say I don't know any more than
this very very brief statement that's
been made tonight but um and I guess you
know the one thing we can all pretty
much guarantee is that your colleagues
in the other newspapers I've got no
doubt what's going to be on the front
pages
tomorrow yeah and all week I expect um
but no I we haven't had a a monar with a
serious illness certainly in my lifetime
I mean if the queen did ever have a
serious illness we never really knew
about it so this is quite new for for a
lot of us isn't it yeah so you'll have
to go away tonight and think well how
does the Sunday Times News Review do
something that nobody else has done all
week yeah I only three calls from my
editor so far this evening
um so onto politics um you know the
obvious place to start is this year's
election
um what is more likely would you say
this year that rishy
sunak somehow wins the election or that
Burnley stay up in the Premier League
both long
shots um neither are
guaranteed
um well that's a very very good question
uh I think that look I I am a
professional pessimist in politics I
always have been and I every time I bump
into members of The Shadow cabinet or
any of Kia's team I say just ignore the
polls when they're like this ignore them
um because I I really genuinely do worry
that if you add together the sense of
kind of apathy and cynicism that's
around about politics
anyway um added to which large parts of
the the media I don't know why I went
like that large parts of the media stand
in for all all media large parts of the
media are going to be utterly vile about
ktha between now much of the election
and the election it's you know I keep
saying to Kia it hasn't even started yet
it's going to get very very nasty um so
you put that together with I guess you
know this is my worry about Labor I
think at the moment there's too much
about what labor are not as opposed to
what they are and that's fine I think
that's fine to have been there for part
of this Parliament but I think to really
get the sort of win that I think is
there for the
taking um I'd like to see more from
labor but it's very very hard to see how
the Tories survive it's not just r unach
I mean I feel a bit sorry for him in a
way no I don't feel sorry um but I I you
know he's followed he's followed the two
people who will be analyzed in history
only for which one was the worst prime
minister that we ever had uh Johnson and
Trust so he's he's picked up this thing
and then we've had but you know honestly
I can't think of a single thing that's
got better in this country in the last
13 years so I don't understand how they
could even think that they might get
reelected but there's a little part of
me that says until people go out and
vote then whoever's in government stays
in government so they have to be voted
out and um well it's a massive swing as
well I mean it needs a historic it's a
huge swing we had um HS us off on the PO
on the podcast this morning I near he
said the newspaper um and I made the
point that because he's H us has now got
this new line that you know K is going
to win anyway and it's a way of saying
so you can still vote SNP but if
Scotland stays as it did at the last
election K labor have to win Jacob re
Moy which we never did so the swing is
massive it's bigger than Atley it's
bigger than Blair so it's it's not a
done deal it's not a done deal which is
why you have to get out and vote and
persuade your friends to get out and
vote as long as it's not for the
Tories so I
mean the the the framework that's often
put on the debate at the moment is is
this a 92 moment or a 97 moment I you
know these are not perfect analogies
it's clearly it's a 2024 moment but um
you were obviously there well very much
there in '97 but also very much around
in '92 as
well where would you put this election
relative to those two just if you were
if you were forced to well look how old
are you 18 right so when were you born
uh 2005 there you go it's about it's
about the future not the past um so he
was born in 2005 I was in his primary
school this morning honestly you want
him to answer the question yeah what is
your
answer
92977 well the Paul said 97 so I'll
probably go with okay he's going 97 he's
an optimist okay I was in a school this
morning and it was honestly they hadn't
heard of David Cameron wow they didn't
know who David Cameron was I mean he is
now the foreign secretary again yeah I
know I know but but they don't really
follow politics right they're their kids
in a primary school sorry I didn't
realiz a primary school Primary School
sorry right
okay yeah yeah I thought it was like an
a level politics it was politics it
wasn't a primary school sorry um but
this one really cheered me up they
didn't know who Piers Morgan was okay
yeah they didn't know who aren venger
was did they know who alist Campbell was
well only because I was there only
because I was there
because I I was going but so my point is
is that look 9297 I remember 1992
vividly because I was still a journalist
but I was covering it but I was also and
still am a very close friend of Neil
kinck I don't think I didn't think labor
were going to win um because the more
that I'd gone around the country and the
buildup to it I just I met too many
people who were saying they were going
to vote Tor who I didn't expect to vote
Tori 97 I thought we were going to win
but I didn't think we were going to win
as big as we did um but look the the
most obvious comparison is 1997 for
these reasons the Tories have been in
for a very long time there have been a
lot of scandals the country feels stuck
the labor party has gone through a
process of change since Jeremy Corbin um
so I think that's what feels more kind
of fitting to the moment but at the same
time I think there are other things
going on that that didn't happen back
then I think that uh I think social
media I think the fact that the Tories I
don't I've got no idea what the Tories
are up to in terms of campaigning but it
won't be pretty and it'll be very very
well funded so I think I think 97 is my
short answer but it is 2024 and it's
very very it's a very different
political landscape so just to let you
know we will be taking some questions at
the end and if you're watching online as
well you can put questions in um to take
a go back alist to 97 then there's this
metaphor that sometimes used that Tony
Blair had was something about carrying a
Ming V across a room um that basically
all he had to do was not drop the
election because it was his to win my
the sort of popular memory of 97 is
things can only get better and parades
down Downing Street and it was all sort
of somewhat
inspirational um in a very British way
but was it like that at the time or or
was Blair actually was it quite a
campaign or did it feel like a sort of a
landslide in the making a momentous
moment the the Ming vas thing was
actually Roy Jenkins who said that he
said that his assessment of our campaign
was we it was like we were carrying a
Ming vas and we were terrified of
dropping it um it's interesting I was
interviewed recently for a documentary
somebody's making a documentary called
1996 it's mainly about football I think
this of last The Oasis and that stuff
yeah yeah it's a lot about Gaza and uh
so I was interviewed for it so I thought
the night before the interview I thought
well I bet I'll go and check my Diaries
just to sort of you know flick through
so I read through them and of course
even my sort of institutional memory
because it is of 1997 you know we were
completely clear about we wanted to do
we're in control everything was going
well I read my diary it was a
nightmare it was like you know nothing
was going right it was all people were
falling out with scandals so I think
that I didn't think on the night of the
election
itself um Tony and I were up in
sedgfield and we'd got to the the count
where Tony T Tony's constituency count
and we we were told we got about an hour
to kill before the result and we were
watching the TV and I I'll never forget
this it was like we were winning in
seats where we hadn't even campaigned
there was one moment where there labor
MP came on turn you who is
that we we because we it was in a place
we hadn't expected to win at all so that
only came at the end and that's why I
say I I remain I think it's right to be
cautious about predicting landslides or
anything else because you know it can go
the other way it can go the other way
the campaign felt pretty good but you
know this this 28 billion thing that's
going on at the moment where I just wish
to hell that sort the answer out and fix
it we had a a situation nobody will
remember this but in 1997 the first
couple of the campaign we had this whole
big thing about Air Traffic Control
privatization that became the big story
nobody will remember this right but it
became the big thing for about four or
five days so you you can never quite
tell what's going to flare up in a
campaign campaigns people can make
mistakes as well as do things well so no
it didn't feel easy at all it felt
really really hard right to the end it's
interesting I'll bring us up to the
present now as you say that that's all
ancient history in some ways but but
fascinating to compare but but you
mentioned the media I'd actually push
back a little bit on that from a from
from a my vantage point certainly I
think starm has done pretty well to uh
get on with the Murdoch media as as
Blair did as well in '96 famously um and
I also think that even the parts of the
media that will go for him have
struggled thus far to lay a glove on him
I always think about that do you
remember that ridiculous story The M did
about the donkey oh the donkey the
donkey yeah yeah there was sort of story
about this great sort of do people know
about the donkey do you want to explain
to us about the donkey well it's the
Donkey Sanctuary right so Kia stama um
had a mom who was spent a lot of her she
had Still's disease she was very ill a
lot of his
childhood um and she liked to sit
outside the back and look in this field
and and and he eventually got the field
so that he could save this Donkey
Sanctuary um which if you think about it
it's quite a nice story about a nice
workingclass boy doing something nice
for his mom the male turned it into a
whole thing about how he was like a sort
of property Speculator you know trying
to buy trying to portray him as this
sort of so you're right they didn't land
the glove but it doesn't mean they won't
try um I do think K's quite good at
being elusive as a
Target um and Tony was good at being
elusive as a Target as well Tony went
from being Bambi to Starin in about 6
months um so they they haven't yet
decided on how they're going to go for
care but that they will sure is for sure
where I think the change has been I
don't think the newspapers are nearly as
important as they were for pretty
obvious technological reasons but they
still to my mind disproportionately set
the broader political agenda certainly
within the conservative party and the
conservative party seems to me spend all
their time talking to the telegraph the
mail and to some extent the times and
the Sun that is where the conversation's
taking place and the public well let's
not worry about them too much much so
and that then sets the broadcast agenda
which is where I still think a lot of
people consume yes and even if people
say well I consume my politics online
which lots of people do the stuff that
is being fed towards them a lot of it is
still being channeled through what a
newspaper yeah it's BBC Clips it's talk
TV Clips well it's like tonight you know
the news is actually leading on an
interview that Piers Morgan has done
with yeah with Richie sunak which no one
to watch live few people but they'll see
clips of that something will go viral
and and I have to say it's like I have
people heard about this interview so on
the one there's two big stories coming
out of it the first is Rishi sunak has
admitted that he's not met uh the the
Health Service pledge that he made when
he did his five priorities and the
second thing is k um K St Piers Morgan
making a, bet that no refugees will go
to Rwanda okay and rather ill advisedly
in my view Rishi sunak seems to have
taken the BET by shaking Piers Morgan's
hand Alistair is it fair to say ill
advisedly as a slight understatement on
your
part you low well the thing I'd say in
Pier's Morgan's defense even though he
regularly calls me a liar um I think
that might have to something do
something with the sort of fact that I'm
a bit pissed off that he was hacking my
phone while he was the editor
um shots fired what shots fired
I so but so if you think about this as
as a thing though is that Piers Morgan
he sees his job and has done all his
life as trying to get attention for
himself and his TV channel now okay
Rishi Sun's job is to be the Prime
Minister and lead the country so when I
say ill advised don't help
him Morgan do his job at the detriment
of you doing your job which I'm afraid
is what happened and I could feel that
from the Ripple people immediately think
oh my god did he really do that well he
did well it didn't strike me as great
politics and and that actually was going
to be my next question anyway which is
is Rishi tunak as bad as at
Politics as he seems to be and if so
why well I see what you've got to be
very very very
particular to think
that the place to announce that you're
scrapping
hs2 is the Tory Party Conference in
Manchester that takes a
political
Wizardry that I cannot quite grasp um
and also he's got look we the thing
about politicians is we're all human
beings we we we try to make them what we
want them to be so people will say why
can't Kia starma be a bit more
charismatic why can't R you could you
why can't Rite be taller well he can't
right why can't he be less Rich well
because he likes making loads of money
or his wife does so you know they are
what they are but he does seem I I think
that I was a journalist when Mrs thater
was prime minister right and this goes
you know more broadly I think that there
probably has been a diminution of the
political Gene fewer and fewer people
think about going to politics for all
sorts of reasons I hope you guys think
about going to politics I've got a young
group down here by the way is just to
indicate to the older people at the back
um The Young Ones got here really early
um but I think that I'm not sure that
richy sunite would have got into
Maggie's cabinet right I think he might
have got a job as a junior Minister but
I think that's I don't want to be
personal I don't want to be rude but I
kind of think that's his
level um
sorry I hope that wasn't personal rude
but that is I mean that is a bro that is
an issue that is much broader than Rich
you the caliber of and it's partly
because we've been through about three
sets of Tory politicians at this point
yeah so we are sort of and the and
Johnson who terrible human being but he
threw out people like Rory Stewart Ken
Clark you know David gwk people who you
could at least look at and think I can
imagine them as cabinet ministers I
don't think they're ridiculous people so
he got rid of all them so now I mean
honestly there are people who have been
you know just just think we live in a
country where for the rest of her life
LZ truss will get an
allowance for the fact that she was the
Prime Minister LZ truss just remember
this she will be at the senath every
year see I think that's a curse
though
well she'll ha it yeah but she probably
though she will love it she'll love it
because it'll be her reminder
so I just think that's absurd and but if
I think back to the Thatcher major time
right and it's amazing isn't it I mean
John Major when he came on the podcast I
remember sitting there thinking I used
to be vile about this guy and I now
think God I wish he was back you know
even Theresa May I think wish she was
back I mean what's happened to me so um
so I think there has been a
diminution um but the truth is it you
don't need that many
really really good people you need a few
really really good people and then you
need a a very large cohort of good
strong competent people but I feel at
the moment we don't we neither have the
really good people nor the competent
cohort and it's it's terrible it's
terrible they've got to go they've got
to go and then I hope I hope that labor
can come in and really give the country
a sense of energy and direction and
change because I mean these guys their
generation I I was in a school the other
day right and this girl she was about 15
and she actually got a laugh she didn't
mean to get a laugh she got a laugh in
the classroom but I felt really sad by
what she said she said she said has
politics always been this
bad and I just thought that's all she's
known I said what was your first memory
of politics she said it was my parents
arguing about brexit and I I just think
since brexit this country has completely
lost its way
politically so I think we'll towards the
end we'll get back to little bit of the
more constructive stuff on on what can
be done there but I just wanted to ask
you a little bit about leadership which
is a great theme of your writing and
podcasting um and
starma on the one hand I think he's
exhibited some quite strong qualities of
leadership in terms of the way he's
taking control of the party again and
he's been quite he's very ruthless on
the other hand as you've alluded to he
doesn't I don't think even he would say
he's a hugely charismatic man he doesn't
give a resounding speech um lots of
people say they find him a bit dull and
a bit boring how do you assess him as a
leader his strengths and weaknesses well
I think the assessment you have to make
is based upon what he's done to take the
labor party from where it was um now
accepted he's had a lot of help from the
Tories okay but he's gone from a place
where in
2019 people were really beginning to
think as the labor party had its day I
remember doing an interview on the day
you know on the day of the defeat saying
that no party has a divine right to
exist so he's gone from that to a place
where now the criticism he gets is you
know why isn't it absolutely blindingly
obvious that there's going to be a
massive
Landslide um so I I think you'd have to
say that he's done a pretty good job at
showing the change um and I can remember
after the Harlot poool byelection he
came around for a cup of tea because you
know lives quite near us and he came
around for a c te and and I was in you
know I'm quite kind of that was the n
really wasn't it really was and I was
saying you know what I care I don't
understand what is the strategy what is
the plan I don't see what's going on and
he said and and and I've seen him say
this many many times since and I've seen
other people say it and it's the it's
the moment when I realize that I think
actually he does have quite a strategic
mind it just works differently to the
way that I Define strategy doesn't mean
that's right or wrong either is it right
or wrong and he said this he said look
I've got to try to do in one
parliamentary term through three stages
first stage show the labor party is not
the Corban party it's changed and people
have got to understand that okay now
here we are in pretty much Jeremy Corbin
territory hands up if you think the
labor party has changed in the last few
years okay so that's pretty overwhelming
yeah second stage he said show that the
conservatives are unfit to
govern well as you say he may he may
have had a bit of help may but I think
and also do think is and it's true he's
not he's not a Barack Obama orator he's
not a Bill Clinton get the hairs on your
next standard but I think he's both his
speaking and his interviews and his
performance in Parliament have all
improved and that's an important Point
as well because he's you know he's he's
he's not much younger than I am he's
getting on a bit right so so but he has
improved all of those things but I think
the third part he then said then the
third part is to show if not them why us
and that has to be about policy now that
that's the bit that I think they really
need to kind of focus on and crank up
now and I think what they're doing is
getting the negatives out the way I hope
what they're doing they've got these
five missions I hope those five missions
by the time of the election turn into
some pretty clear concrete stuff that
everybody knows and everybody
understands and the thing is at the
moment I feel the country is is it's
really in most elections you've got an
opposition
and people are kind of this definitely
happened with Jeremy Corbin I think it
happened with Neil back in 1992 you got
people who think well I might be tempted
but I'm going to I want to find reasons
not to vote for
them I think with labor at the moment if
they could just T you know be a bit less
defensive I think the country is looking
for reasons to vote for them and that's
the it's a different Dynamic so give us
the reasons to vote for we we we had a
friend we got France a lot we've got a
friend out there who lives near where we
go and and this guy he's he's British
but but he's voted Tori all his life and
he says I cannot vote Tori again I
cannot vote Tori but he said but but
starma has to give me a song to whistle
to and I thought it was a really good
phrase it was like what is the song I'm
forget the Tories what am I whistling to
and uh that's what I'd like to see in
the next bit but you use the word
ruthless by the way and I think he is
quite ruthless and that is not to be
underestimated in politics well he's
also as you pointed out he is more
strategic than people give him credit
for I think he he worked out quite early
on that it was going to be good politics
to be ruthless with the with the corite
left when when there was a clear
crossing of the the boundaries he'd set
and so he's not been afraid to do it
really from day one yeah yeah listen you
know Tony was seen as a pretty strong
Bowl leader in lots of different ways
but would Tony have actually expelled
Jeremy Corbin from the party well he
never did
um but go back to 97 for a moment there
was a lot of money in the kitty then or
a lot more money in the kitty then and
so Blair and Gordon Brown could lay out
basically improving Public Services
through spending which they then you
know to some extent did clearly that's
not the case anymore so just
structurally is it quite a disadvantage
there no it's different it's definitely
different I look we we I think that look
the Tories are very very good at writing
long-term narratives okay so if you
listen to them now you say well 1997 we
we you inherited a sort of golden age
it's absolute bollocks um there was M
there was inflation back in the system
and massive unemployment so we had a lot
of economic problems we had to here but
what is true not just economically I'd
say economically socially
culturally strategically on the security
front internationally I think labor if
they win will inherit a much
trickier Wicket than we did I really do
think they will
but and and I think there's two things
I'd say about that one that is why you
do have to have a sense of a long-term
Vision um and be clear about what that
is and what sort of time frame you're
talking about the country will listen to
Somebody even though they know it takes
two election they'll listen to people
talking about 10 years you know a decade
to do this a decade to do that um and
the second thing I'd say is that when if
and when labor get in you have to have
you get energy you get momentum through
change that that will you know that the
thing about the the sort of flag waving
in Downey Street and what have you you
do have moments that can give you a
sense of this is changed this gives you
energy this gives you momentum and
during the period because the truth is
in our political system change does take
time turn around the Health Service it's
going to take a long time that he talks
about growth through reform of the
planning system that is not going to be
easy so you're going to have to have
alongside that what I call cost neutral
campaigning and policy issues and the
one for me that I think really lends
itself to Karma's personality and to
labor party values is actually about
trying to restore values in public
standards in public life right I think I
think the I think the the labor party
underestimate the power that there is in
saying to the public you know what
things saying to that girl no politics
wasn't always this bad politics doesn't
always have have to be this bad we are
going to restore basic standards in
public life and I would love it for
example if he stood up and said you know
what John Major he was right when he
talked about the need for the nol and
principles he was right when he talked
about we should have an expectation of
honesty in public life there should be
openness there should be transparency we
should be here to serve not to help
ourselves with all this I mean the
levels of corruption that are happening
in our politics now I am staggered I'm
staggered that with one or two
exceptions this stuff going up in tside
and the Free Port stuff at the moment
it's happening with next to no debate
and look there was a report last week
saying that they haven't proven
corruption but they've certainly
established governance systems that
simply aren't working so I think if he
were to say stand up and say all that
and then say and mean it if a single
minister in a labor government offends
any one of those seven Nolan principles
they are out and then he has to do it
and I think that would I think it would
transforms people's perception of
politics at the moment you know I I
spent all my life defending politics and
the book really is a defense of politics
okay but at the moment when somebody
says to me I was this school I went to
today in dagam I arrived a bit early and
I went to this Cafe for a just to get a
cup of coffee and there's a guy say next
to me he recognizes me starts talking
what have you and he said I mean the
trouble is they're all in it up to their
necks they're all in it for themselves
and now people have said that about
politics forever okay and I I've always
argued that it's not true but I kind of
look at the
recent government and I get why he's
saying it so labor I think can change
that so I would say go for the cultural
stuff you know go for the changing
standards in public life and I also
think by the the way things like the
arts and culture which are so often
being seen as kind of like melvan Bragg
made this speech in the house this week
it was really good and he said you know
arts and culture aren't the cherry on
the cake they are the cake and I think
Britain you know we've had all this Guff
from Johnson and Truss about world
beating this and World beating that you
know we've got an army now that you can
fit inside the bloody Yeti had you know
and he's talking about I mean it's just
nonsense and then he says he signed up
for conscription did you see that I mean
so I think that we where we can be World
beating is if we can restore the values
genuine respect for rule of law and
democracy and all that but also in
culture we can be a cultural superpower
so that's the sort of vision I want to
see from Kia so that lack of trust in
politics and in politicians I mean as
you say to ever us to some extent but
clearly it's it's it's got worse in
recent years where do you root that to I
mean do you how much of that is about
brexit and the brexit wars
do you go back further lots of people
might say the Iraq War and and which
obviously you were central figure in
take you know the black government
taking Britain to war in Iraq was a a
great loss of trust in politics so where
do you I think look there's there's
never been a kind of housian period when
people have thought oh I love my
politicians you know but I think I think
I think politicians have always had a
certain respect a residual respect I
think there have been a number of things
I think MPS expenses did a huge amount
of damage I think the global financial
crisis I say in the book I think the
real the real trigger for this
successful populism was the global
financial crisis where people felt the
people who caused it got away with it
and we the people paid the price um Iraq
definitely um I think that you have to
accept that you know I know Tony didn't
lie I know I didn't lie but when you
have made as part of your case the fact
you have stated in your honest
conviction that this is about tackling
Saddam Hussein and weapons of mass
destruction and the inspectors go in and
they don't find them that's a pretty
obvious trust moment um so all of these
things come together and I think you
know more recently I do think that I I
think one of the reasons why the
interesting I saw a very interesting
polling presentation by John Curtis a
few weeks ago the two moments that have
really moved the dial in our politics
um in recent years have been party gate
and the trust mini
budget um party gate I think was was I
think people felt genuinely
fundamentally offended by that yes and
defended by the lying That Then followed
but I think that I I do for my point I
do think brexit is a big factor in this
because I think that as a country we've
moved on from the single most important
and significant change that has been
made Through The Ballot Box we've moved
on from it despite the fact that it did
involve lies and law breaking and there
has been no accountability for for
either so Johnson went eventually
because of the lies over party gate he's
never been held accountable for brexit
so I think all of that combines to make
people think
well is there much Point getting
involved and that's what I'm trying to
address in the book is yes there is
because we have to get more and better
people involved in the political process
de with brexit I
mean I sometimes wonder if in in recent
years if you mentioned hs2 earlier and
sometimes I wonder if actually what
brexit and to some extent the pandemic
to have done is actually reveal a sort
of deeper rot that had set in beforehand
um to to this is what within Public
Service yeah and within public life and
within within our institutions and that
actually we sort of been drifting it's
it's a bit like you know if you have a
terrible breakup in your life or
something and then you suddenly realize
that actually your friends you sort have
drifted from them for quite a while or
something and to what extent do you put
Britain's predicament now with down to
brexit versus this kind of deeper Mala
that I think I think brexit was the peak
um and look I do think there's been a
you mentioned institutions part of what
populism does is to under M institutions
because the institutions which are there
to hold politicians to account to ensure
the rule of law to ensure a free and
fair media all these
institutions um if you're a populist
who's trying to say to people I can be a
I can solve this complicated Problem by
giving you a simple slogan to that you
can sort of tie your tie your flag to
then the institutions fall victim to
that um and I actually think I say in
the book I think we have to do a better
job of protecting the institutions
particularly and that's difficult from a
progressive perspective normally the
progressives are the ones who are saying
the institutions have to be modernized
and changed but actually I I think the
rule of law in particular we've got to
be really really careful about that but
I think there has been a kind of a rot I
I do think I hate doing that thing where
journalists can say oh you always blame
the media I'm not all only blaming the
media I do think that media coverage of
politics has been really corrosive about
politics and politics Poli itics has not
done a good job of Defending itself and
our political system doesn't lend itself
to it I think for example that you know
the fact that most of what people see of
politics is a minister says something
the shadow Minister attacks it and then
somebody comes along and says well it's
probably not going to work anyway and
the sort of General sense is this just
this dysfunctional and I do think I I I
really think we need to have a complete
overhaul of the whole political system
starting with political education in
schools which is why I keep going to
schools and trying to talk to kids about
politics lowering the voting age
compulsory
voting definitely a look at the
electoral system um I don't I'm not one
of those people who thinks PR is some
kind of Panacea is not but our electoral
system feels broken um probably even
greater Devolution to the towns and
cities and regions and the the nations
of the UK um I just feel we we're at a
point where we we feel broken it feels
broken and the only way to to fix it is
to be honest about that and then to say
okay as a country what are we going to
do about that and I worry that the
elections are going to be about very
small things when it should be about big
things it's funny you mention
ministerial announcements because it's
something we've noticed at at the Sunday
times in the last year or two which is
readers aren't responding to your
classic political interview anymore uh
they're not really interested in Reading
sort of oldfashioned political coverage
anymore so we're actually having to look
at quite different ways to cover
politics and connect it to people's
lives or issues um so you know in the
sense that the media does have to
respond to its readers there is there is
seemingly a shift out there I hope there
is because I I think it's become
incredibly
formulaic um you know if you think about
so that you get the Sunday papers they
go into the Sunday shows the same person
does the round says the same thing that
leads the new for the day that sets the
debate for the Monday and I think for a
lot of people they're just not even
listening anymore I think that system is
breaking down I really do I hope it does
I hope it does it needs to from the
front line that's how it looks to me but
um and to be honest that's why I think I
mean I've been absolutely stunned by the
success of our podcast but I think it is
actually because it's it's just a bit
more thoughtful and deep than what I
think people feel they getting from
turning on the Telly and watching the
news Well we can thank Rory Stewart for
that
but
that's definitely the best line so far
and he will be so happy and I know
there's a friend of his who's here
tonight who'll be texting him right now
saying um you mentioned you mentioned
populism obviously there are many other
big elections happening this year uh
India we just had Taiwan but there'll be
a lot of attention on America you're
quite a keen student of American
politics um I'm not going to ask you
who's going to win cuz it's it's
something akin to a coints but what do
you make of it all do I mean I have
written in the past I I spent a few
years in Washington that I just thought
from day one they were mad to run Joe
Biden again given his age and you know
sort of General Vibe
um what do you think do you do you think
that was a mistake or is that is it too
too is that premature do you think
well if you see it from his perspective
I mean Trump is
a awful
phenomenon but he is a phenomenon and
you know we we I spoke to Hillary
Clinton when she was in Belfast for the
25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement and you know I said it's
really hard to look back it must be
incredibly hard for her she's written a
whole book about how hard it is but I
don't know what she could have done
differently in the campaign because she
was up against this
phenomenal she could have gone to
Wisconsin that was the she could have
lot lots of could have would have should
have but my point is on the strategy she
pursued I can understand it now Biden
did beat him he beat him and we talked
to this guy Tu rescu on the podcast last
week who's a Republican strategist who's
now in the kind of anybody but Trump um
camp and he said the thing you have to
understand about to become the American
president you have to think that that
you can be the American president and
even though lots of people might say oh
I could do that very very very very few
people on Earth say to themselves do you
know what I could be American president
and mean it Joe Biden thinks he can
still be American president and I think
unless Jill his wife says to him Joe
don't do it which there's no sign she is
saying that he's going to go for it at
which point then it has to become well
want him or do you want the other guy um
now I agree with you I think that a lot
of people will be
thinking you know is he going to survive
four years do we really want Cala Harris
Etc um equally I still think he's got a
good record to point to he's a pretty
good
campaigner and trump orbe it he's a
phenomenon he's actually a pretty easy
political
Target um but IE you know everywhere
everybody I talking to America says you
know can't they both just disappear
that's kind of the feeling of it I still
think I I think Biden will win though
well there was I mean the reason he won
last time well the main reason he won
was that there was a there was a
constituency and they call them swing
voters called the moderates who just
couldn't face Trump again yeah they they
didn't necessarily like Biden they're
not necessarily liberal but they just s
this guy we just want to switch him down
switch him off turn the volume down and
they were just exhausted by it and I I
do think that constituency is still
there um but you you must be pretty
worried by some of the polling at the
moment I mean obviously we're months out
the polling is terrific but don't forget
if you go back to the midterms Trump was
dead Trump was finished it was all over
things swing around very very quickly I
still think the bit I mean Trump clearly
thinks that every time he's on T every
time he's got the chance to be on TV in
one of these courtrooms he takes it
because thus far it's helped him up I
think that will I think it could go the
other way quite quickly I think there
will come a point where the legal
troubles become too bad and and also I I
but you know your initial question was
what do I think has happened I find it
unfathomable I mean I covered Thatcher
Reagan I just I I I actually mentioned
in the book about a speech Reagan
Reagan's last look up Reagan's last
speech as American president okay it's
an amazing piece of oratory but the
other thing that's incredible about it
you couldn't imagine Donald Trump saying
one word that he says it's actually a p
of praise to immigrants it's an amazing
speech um so what has gone and the other
thing we talked to Tucker about this is
that because he's a kind of big
Christian guy I just don't know what's
happened in the American psyche that
have you seen the Trump made God film
the Trump God made Trump no I haven't oh
you got to see it it's about
evangelicals yeah it's the evangelicals
have made this film called God made
Trump
it's not funny it's terrifying it's
terrifying that they they believe that
so what has happened to that psyche I
just don't know the answer to that
question you probably have a better feel
for it because you lived there yeah well
I spent spent a lot of time in those
Evangelical churches um mostly getting
Co but that's another story um but so
crystal ball say imagine Trump does win
and starma wins um how does starma
approach that I mean even for the
campaign they're still they're already
having to reach out because you need to
have relationships and that sort of
thing um we're as closely alive to
America as we ever were really Poss you
know you see us buming together in the
Middle East yet again um how does how
does starm and labor approach
Trump
um It's Tricky It's Tricky I think you
have to do it like TR made did
it I you you you you you you could tell
from the body language that theres was
not enjoying it but she said the right
things and I think you have to do that
um but you also have to reach a point
where sometimes you have to call him out
um but I I I think that I don't imagine
there's a single person in this Hall who
thinks that not just um K starma but I
suspect richy
sunak would be really worried about the
return of trump I mean the whole thing
with NATO is terrifying yeah it's
terrifying you know and and and it's not
just the fact that he can think about it
it's the fact that he can do it on a
whim and what happened last time is that
you know we all persuaded ourselves that
he'll get in there then the grown-ups
will surround him the grown-ups were
kept out the room and then the ones that
he got in there even though they
couldn't cope with it but they did have
him in they hemmed him in they hemmed
him in but a trump that comes back
having you know what is it Washington is
it the Washington Post that's 5 million
words of Lies they've got this database
of all the lies he told was president
and it goes to 5 million words you've
had the Insurrection You' had people
dying as a result of it you've had
Scandal upon Scandal you've had this
recent liable case I mean we're talking
about a level of this should normally do
for a political career that is up there
and yet he's still in the fight so that
he will be so emboldened if he wins he
literally will be able to think he can
pick up the phone to zilinski and say
Vlad Vladimir is over you're on your own
yeah you're on your own mate you know
it's up to you do you want to do you
want to lose the whole country or do you
want to lose what you've lost already
because I've now got to go and talk to
Kim Jun to say thanks for the nice
letter he sent me last week you know so
I think it's terrifying so I always
think it's it's a great danger sometimes
in British politics to try and draw too
many uh conclusions from American
politics but I would say looking at
Biden it seems to me that one weakness
that he has accured is that he hasn't
really been seen to do anything about
immigration do you think that's
something that starma should take note
of whether in his campaign or if he does
become Prime Minister that actually he
can't afford to not to sit on his hands
on that issue you have to you you look
and not by the way not just G St right
across Europe This is like really big at
the moment and very very difficult um
and you either have to I mean what
Angela Merkel did in you know taking in
a million and shaff andas and all that
um was very big very bold very brave
and you could argue the right thing to
do the political consequences have been
pretty profound um you now have a
situation so here we are we're talking
about you know could Britain get back
into the European Union you know there
is an argument to be made about whether
it is developing into a European Union
that we want to be in um you've got the
Sweden Democrats now in government
you've got the
um we've just had an election in Finland
which actually was pretty good from the
progressive perspective but you've got
Maloney already in power you've got the
afd you know these I I've been really
impressed by these protests against them
but the reason for them is because they
are now so high in the polls in several
parts of the country you've got Builders
okay so is the conclusion from that that
brexit wasn't such a bad idea after all
no brexit
remains how dare you come to my
first first question to
that no I I still think it was a
terrible thing to do and by the way I
think one of the worst things about it
is that Europe has lost the influence of
the UK within it um I I imagine that the
Franco German Alliance which has always
been a big motor would have been
strengthened by a departure bizarrely
it's been
weakened um so you've got you've got
Marine Le Pen she's pretty much doing
nothing at the moment but she could win
um you've got the afda as I say on a
path to government not probably the
they're not going to be the biggest
party but they could be in a position
where they have to be part government so
that's you know that's all evolving and
a lot of that is to do with immigration
so yes it has to be addressed but I
still think that you know one of the
reasons uh I'm obviously I'm not a
nationalist I'm not a supporter of the
SNP but I I do think it's good that
we've at least got one party that sort
of talks up for imig speaks up for
immigration and let's be honest we as a
country getting older and
older um Artificial Intelligence coming
along the way that it is you know the
the the need for immigration is not
going to dry up anytime soon so I I just
wish that we could be a bit more honest
about that but K Kier I think is playing
I completely support what he's trying to
do politically has to do what he's doing
on
immigration so couple more questions
from me and then we're going to go to
the audience so have a think on what you
might want to ask um you mentioned
cynicism earlier and that's a quite a
big theme of the book as well is is
resisting cynicism um I wonder if you
might talk a bit more about that what
what can one do what are the more
constructive approaches to politics that
can overcome the the mistrust the
cynicism uh the apathy frankly that has
set in for a lot of people well it's
hard it's really it's really hard and I
and I get why I think I think first of
all one of the things I try to do in the
book is to be fair and reasonable about
politicians as a breed um there have
been some terrible people in politics um
you know through history but in the main
it's a pretty tough job it's a difficult
thing to do you put yourself out there
particularly in the Modern Age you get
loads of abuse so I think we should all
of us try to see something positive in
them um I think more importantly I think
we should try to resist and this is
really hard it's going to get harder
because of AI and fake news and all that
stuff we should try to resist
going for the first thing that comes at
us about any issue we should try to
inform ourselves better and we should
take more ownership I think of of what
we think about politics as individuals
and as and as communities because I it
and it's very hard to do I found myself
there was classic example today there's
a poll doing the rounds and it says that
labor support among the Muslim Community
has hared since October right it's not
true it's not true when you go down to
the numbers it's way more complicated
than that and but there that's the kind
of thing that I think so when I saw it I
thought okay interesting need to check
it out now what you can't do you can't
spend your whole life being a kind of
you know your own journalist you can't
do that but I think that what I would
say is is
reserve have
skepticism about everything that is put
towards you but don't have cynicism
don't imagine that everybody's lying
lying to you don't imagine that things
can't be improved don't imagine that
things can't work and look for and
enjoy the stuff that does work and you
know there's plenty of it there's plenty
of it yeah I mean one one positive
aspect of the immigration issue is that
lot of people still want to come and
live in this country don't they
absolutely um I would also say I'm
extremely biased on this but I generally
find actually not going to social media
for my news but actually reading
newspapers I trust first gives me much
because they have done gone through the
poll and actually Crums the numbers or
what yeah what I what I tend to do for
my own kind of because it's it's very
hard to know how um I was in secondary
school last last week 17 18 year olds
nobody physically one person physically
read a
paper um about three watched the BBC One
watch Sky none watched GB
news um so they were all on kind of
different Social Media stuff but
actually they kind of they were talking
about all the same things so they kind
of getting there what I do when I'm
interested in something I do now go and
I've I've got one of my gold rules you
read books not newspapers sorry um
reading but you can do both you do both
and the other thing is I I I I I have a
little sort of Michael Gove in my head
saying you know we're sick and tired of
experts and I go and find a genuine
expert on something and I Google them
and I see if they've said anything about
and if they haven't I might send them an
email and say what are your thoughts on
this yeah because not everyone's in the
position to do that I say we are though
we are we are in the position to do that
well they might not reply they might not
well they don't always reply to me
that's fair um last question for me and
then we'll we'll move to the audience
just on the
book it was a it was a number one best
seller say so what impact have you
noticed it having and how did that you
obviously had hope for it in terms of
how you the impact it would have did
that live up to expectation it's very
hard to measure um you'll be pleased to
know as a Rory Stewart Fanboy that his
book is sold even better um somebody
tell Rory I said that as well
um I don't know it's very hard to
measure very hard to measure the impact
of a book um I mean I showed you the
book I was reading the backstage the boy
the strip pajamas it sold 11 million
copies in 50 languages um how do you I
don't know how you measure the impact
but I've been I've been struck
by when I've gone into schools in
particular today classic examples so my
next book's actually politics for
primary schools um so I'm going into to
talk to primary schools and what have
you so today was with this school
council and so these were the last year
so 10 10 year olds in the main and I
said come on then any of you would any
of you think about going into
politics no way no way they said so then
we talked about it for an hour and by
the end end I asked them the same
question and I said right come on we
didn't even think about going to
politics and I had about five
Mayes um what I what I've I have had
messages letters from people who've said
that it's made them think differently
about politics that's that's a minimum
I'd like to achieve um and then then I
have had some I had a letter the other
day from a guy who's decided as a result
of reading the book to try to get a
seat now I had a chat with him and said
I think you know where things are in the
Electoral s he might thinking about
going for a Council seat first but he's
decided he's going to try and get on a
short list fair enough so I've
definitely had people whove said that
this made them want to get I say in the
introduction to the book that my my IM
my vision for it I like to have
long-term Vision I like to visualize
things is that on the day I
die in about 40 years on the day I die
that the
then prime minister
says that this book made them go into
politics
okay moderately ous happen it could
happen
[Laughter]
moderately could be one of these
guys okay so we are going to open up to
questions I hope we got some lights uh
we are going to have some lights we're
going to have some microphone by the way
I know this venue I know this venue
quite well because I come to lots of
folk music events that here all I can
say is I hope you brought
cushions have you because it's they're
not the comest pews are they love no no
keeps everyone alert you know next time
bring a cushion um you've heard this
before but please do ask questions
please don't make statements I beg you
um okay so where are the roving mics do
you want to just find a couple of find a
Pew with a couple of people have their
hands up that looks like a good place to
start hello hi aliser hello um so a lot
of my friends at the moment are really
really pissed off at the labor party
about their stance um on the ceasefire
Etc yeah how do I convince them to go
and vote and that it's about more than
that well you've is that what you want
to do yeah I want to convince them that
they still need to vote you don't share
their anger well I do share their anger
right but I still want to yeah okay um I
suppose all we can do is try to
explain why you think their position is
as it
is and then even if that fails to
persuade them on the specific issue say
that you know in the end you have to
decide whether that is going to stop you
from actually allowing this conservative
government to
continue um because in the end that is
the choice there's no such thing as a
perfect candidate there never has been
Abraham Lincoln was not a perfect human
being Nelson Mandela was not a perfect
human being um now on the position about
why I think why Labor's position is as
it is is SE the several reasons the
first
is I think they don't want it to be
their main thing that's a sort of
tactical political
thing the if and when Kama does become
Prime Minister one of the most important
relationships he's going to have is with
the United
states he will as prime minister have
way more influence on this debate than
he has now does he really want to use up
political Capital now with the Americans
in a way that would make your friends
feel a bit better for a few days before
they then probably got pissed off with
the 28 billion thing okay so I think
it's I think it's explaining it's trying
to
explain that the that the the the the
position that he's adopted is not as
simple cannot be met just by a slogan or
an act which you think will have no
consequences but it could have
consequences does that make sense and
then I think on the bigger picture it's
you know this is the worst government
for young people there has ever been and
you know in a sense you got to say to
them just get off your high horse and
vote
labor
okay um there's a lady there in in the
beige is yeah we're only taking
questions from women yeah sorry N Roses
okay hi um so I think it's very obvious
to sort of everybody really that the
state of society and all of our
institutions are in a pretty sort of
abhorent um position and that's
obviously due to sort of the decade plus
of horrendous policies under uh uh
current and previous governments um so
it's obviously fair to say that whoever
comes into power and hopefully that is
labor will have a you know horrendous
sort of challenge ahead of them so what
advice would you sort of give to the you
know hopefully incoming labor government
about how we reframe and change the
narrative that we've kind of got around
us about Labor being not a safe pair of
hands with the economy and what do you
think our priorities should be when it
comes to public
spending um essentially you thrown your
question like that because of course I
would say that one of the reasons why
some of your friends probably are a bit
pissed off with labor is that the
framing of
economic safety security not frightening
the horses is very much the kind of
driving economic narrative it was
interesting Rachel re and Kier both
spoke at this big business event the
other day and it was very much aimed at
at them you know reassuring them so and
I think that's that's sensible politics
um I think that in terms of of spending
look it's going to be really difficult
there's no doubt about that it's going
to be very very difficult the demands
are going to be enormous you know you
you you've got local government in this
country that is facing meltdown L
literally some of them facing bankruptcy
you've got as I said earlier you've got
this report from the defense select
committee that is really saying our
defenses now are not in a fit State for
the scale of danger that we're facing
you've got people desperate for the
Health Service to be built up You' got
education that is you know you literally
got Schools fall into bits so rebuilding
the public realm when you say what would
my priority be for public spending it's
rebuilding the public realm but it's
going to take a lot of time and I think
it's just it's just being it's being
honest about that but then I think there
has to be I what I hope for K starma I
think I'm reading a book at the moment
Nick Thomas Simmons who's a member of
The Shadow cabinet he's written some
very very good biographies of P labor
leaders and I'm reading his book about
Clement Atley at the moment and I hope
my big hope for gear starm is actually
he's going to be you say 92 97 that it's
going to be more
1945 that it's actually that he's going
to get in and then the country will be
ready for all sorts of things that
aren't even being talked about at the
moment because the the language is very
much about it's about tax it's about
borrowing I think we're going to have to
completely Rec reconfigure how Public
Services are delivered artificial
intelligence is going to be an important
part of that so I I'm hoping that it
will be all of those public services but
it it will be in taking a completely
different approach across the piece and
I think the country will be ready for
that hopefully no rationing um if you're
upstairs we are going to get to you but
you have to queue at the mic I'm told I
don't know where the mic is but if you C
at the mic we will get to you there's a
mic there isn't it that's a mic oh yeah
I see what you mean that's standing mic
that's a mic um see if if I was up there
I'd grab that mic and I'd
sing and this guy looks like a singer
look at him
no um I mean the leather jacket is
pretty okay we'll see is there a do you
have a
question okay well I'll tell you what
we've got one on the iPad first which is
from our digital audience um
counterfactual if Starman loses the next
election what do you think happens to
labor then and I will I will double that
up with a question of my own which is if
you were advising Rishi
sunak how would you advise him to win
this election so maybe start with that
and then and then counterfactual LIF sta
loses what
happens I tell you what I would have
advised if I
did publicly on the podcast as it were
when sunak started as prime minister I
said he has got a very very brief wind
of opportunity to signal that he
genuinely represents ch change M and he
kind of said the right things Integrity
professionalism accountability but then
he didn't do it and I'll tell you the
moment when I started to think this guy
just hasn't got it was the Privileges
report into Johnson I mean he literally
did a runner to avoid being seen he
didn't vote on it he didn't talk about
it it was all it was like just let it go
it'll go away it won't go away because
as I said in that polling thing you know
the party gate thing really cut through
to people so I think now what he would
do look I think the best thing he could
do and this is why the ridiculous thing
with Piers Morgan Tonight goes against
us the thing he should be doing is being
the Prime Minister governing the country
being serious I think some of I think
the way he comes I think how many people
by the way watch prime minister's
questions I'm really fascinated by this
stuff quite a few probably quite an un
sort of politically focused audience
yeah yeah none of them in the primary
school today had ever watched it um but
but I I I I just I just find his whole
stick at Prime Minister's questions I
think is completely counterproductive he
should be serious he should be serious
he should be measured he should be
practical I just think he's he's
listening to these politicos who are
trying to tell him this is how you win a
campaign I think you're you you said
something very interesting about the the
way newspapers are adapting to this new
sens of what politices the campaigners
need to do that as well people are sick
of that stuff so I actually think K when
he stands up there and just kind of he's
just a bit you know people can say it's
dull but he's sort of serious I think
people think he's serious and I think
that's what starma should try um sun
should try to be and just to that point
if if starma does
lose what happens does it swing back to
the left labor or listen if if if labor
if labor
don't
win but by the way if sunite wins I
think it'll be the first time ever
that any party has won as many elections
as this law have right and you got to
remember this for labor I like to say
this because I'm one of the few PE
people still standing who will always
defend Tony Blair um and I don't even
get paid for it these days um not by him
anyway uh you're probably the only
person that doesn't at this
point yeah he's built up a very good
organization but if you go through the
last 11 elections in this country it
goes like this from a labor perspective
Ive lost lost lost lost Blair Blair
Blair lost lost lost lost right so if
labor lose
again then I think the labor party has
an existential question to
answer okay um we've got two let's take
two questions from so both of you up
there sure um hi aliser hello um aside
from maybe encouraging people to go to
be a politician to be an MP or whatever
what about potentially encouraging
people to to work in Civil Service work
in political journalism I feel like
that's also totally fallen off really
and so what would your advice be to
someone who's maybe thinking about that
but maybe has doubts yeah well well
let's just take second question
from thank you Alistair um sunak brought
back um an Undisputed failure in Cameron
into government uh if Kia becomes prime
minister should he invite an
extraordinarily successful and able
person in Tony
Blair and if so in what capacity and
would he be
interested good
question very good question right well I
I'll take the first one because it's
easier
um the no you're absolutely right and by
the way the book has got a whole thing
about politics is not just politicians
politics is campaigners politics is
think tanks politics is as you say the
Civil Service they shouldn't be
political but it's part of the political
process politics is local parties it's
campaigners politics is anything and
anyone who decides to use their voice to
try to make a difference um so my advice
to everybody is first of all decide
whether you want to make a difference
once you've just and most people do once
you've done that decide what are the
things you really really care about and
then decide how can you best how are
your best place to do that now for some
people I know lots of people who are
absolutely passionate about issues but
would no more want to be a elected
politician than fly to the moon they
just couldn't imagine themselves doing
it but they do other things you know so
I I think your question is a brilliant
question because that is the mindset I
think we all have to have what you know
the question is but what can I do that
is why I call the book what can I do
what can I do what can you do and then
within the time frame that you have from
your profession your family other
interests in your life wanting to be a
normal human being what time can you
commit then how do you commit it and I
do think I you know I think to change
the the scale of change that I think
this country needs it's going to need
way more than a change of government
it's going to way need way more than
politicians to do it it's going to need
all of
us yeah um
so on
the I've got to say the thing about
David Cameron coming back
um it's very
rare because these guys do sort of in
the main find out what's going on it's
very rare that you get something we just
go wow I never saw that cup you saw the
chef on the BBC when when C Street
genuine that was I think David C just
went in the building um but so
I I get where your question is coming
from and I will never ever forgive
Cameron either for austerity or for the
fact that he had the ridiculous
referendum um but I think he's I got say
I think he's doing quite a good job I
think he's he's definitely putting the
hours in uh I think his big problem for
sunak is I think he looks and sounds
much more like a prime
minister um but and the question about
about
Tony
um
I don't I don't think K will ask him
poor Tony no I don't I don't I don't
look I think that the the the the big
difference about the thing is that KIA
definitely knows that every single one
of that new labor team whether it's Tony
whether it's Gordon whether it's me
whether it's Peter mandus he knows that
if there's anything that he thinks we
can usefully provide by the way of
thinking and advice and experience the
rest of it that everybody's up for it
whereas I don't think sunac really can
feel that about most of his
predecessors um and no that is a big
that is a big difference that is a big
difference so I think that I don't think
he needs to I think he's got I think I
actually think the other thing that's
happened in the last year or so I think
I actually do feel the shadow cabinet
has grown as well
um I think Angela Raina is an I mean if
you haven't listened to her interview
with us on the podcast it's just she's
just amazing
person um what's the um what's the
relationship between starmer and Blair
like how do I mean good do they do they
talk often yeah I think they they chat
yeah I think um Tony's you know it's he
he doesn't
bombard um I I also think you know I
mentioned the gentleman the Rockstar guy
um the the the whole Think Tank I think
Tony's Institute is producing some
really really really interesting policy
ideas um and and I think that's the
other part of our politics has hollowed
out you know the think tank world has
just been taken over by these you know
tufton street they're basically just an
extension of the
political game as opposed to you know we
need the resolution Foundation does some
great stuff um we need you know think
tanks have got a really important role
in policy development and so I think
Tony sees his role more as that um but
I'm sure if Kia pH him and said I'm a
bit tired today do you want to take over
you I think you'd go for
that um we have some people God there
let's try let's try doing all three so
you're going to have to remember okay
need a pen for that let's do it can I
have a bit of paper yeah thank you yeah
I'm listening two parts one why do we
never get a female labor leader two
should the next Labor leadership vote be
an all women short list okay okay next
question um today there was a report
that was backed by Lord Robertson your
first the chief um defend secretary um
talking about how Ireland is a back door
for Russia and Iran and such how do the
EU Ireland is a back door for Russia and
Iran through their
neutrality how do with an EU you hoping
to expand and hopefully to have us back
in it one day how does Europe deal with
Irish and swiss neutrality and
such did George say that yeah well it
was a report that was backed by him
right okay and Michael Fallen
okay hi um so I I read the first volume
of your diary is like like a year and a
half ago and one of the things that
struck me there's like a passage I think
it's in the early like 2000s where
you're having a conversation with Tony
Blair and he says you know shall we do
PR I I think you you maybe are
advocating for yes and he goes oh you
know I've thought about it I think it's
too much constitutional reform in one go
and but you're like oh you know let's
put the Tories out for a generation and
you know and in the end he decides no
right and does it ever kind of keep you
up at night that you know had you done
that you know all this all this mess you
know
brexit you would have you would have
kept out for a
[Applause]
generation did I say that cuz I was
always very I was always a bit of a PR
skeptic because I've but I and I still
blow hot and cold on it um do I wish
we'd kept the choice out for a
generation yes I absolutely do uh do I
think that PR might be part of the way
of doing that in the future yeah
possibly um
does it keep me awake at I no given your
given your concerns around popularism I
mean PR is is also a way for populist
parties to you know get absolutely I
mean look Builders Builders has just won
the Dutch
election um now he's still not been able
to form a government um but that has its
own disadvantage as well he's actually
gone considerably up in the polls since
the election because he's not been able
to form a government because the other
parties are trying to trying to stop him
I mentioned the afd in Germany I mean
they you know they are on the March and
it's it's it's a it's a PR system so I
don't think PR is a Panacea but as I
said earlier I do think our electoral
system is bust uh and we have to we have
to think about how we change it I
actually think also one one of the
things we talk a lot about on the
podcast is this whole citizens
assemblies thing I think it could be the
first example of how you might use a
citizen assem to try to come up with a
different political system one it would
expose to the country just how hard it
is to do there's no such thing as an
easy perfect political system um on the
Irish Swiss neutrality thing I I don't I
don't know what I think about that I'd
have to check it out I hate talking
about things that I don't I don't know
what the context is um but I don't think
there's a problem I think I think within
the European Union I don't buy the idea
that having Ireland neutrality is is
somehow sort of huge strategic issue for
the rest of Europe or for NATO I don't
get that but I will I will look that up
because I'd be surprised if George that
was his view but could be wrong um on
the female we've technically we've had
two women leaders Harriet Harman and
Margaret Becket have both been leaders
of the labor party in interim roles Okay
I accept that's not the same um but I
thought it was
interesting that there was I felt quite
a muted reaction to the second part of
your question I'm a great believer in
Orin short list and I was in 1997 and I
think we we sort of we broke a lot of
eggs to make a few omelets and we got
some great women into Parliament I think
when it comes to the choice of who's
going to be the leader of the labor
party and therefore the person that you
think should be the Prime Minister I
think for that position to say we're
cutting it down to 50% of the population
I I I don't support that now um I do
support for example what happens in I
think the Welsh I think I'm right the
Welsh assembly now has a system which
guarantees there are 5050 roughly men
and women within the assembly and I
think we've now got a majority of women
in the in the Welsh executive but I
think for the position of prime minister
no I wouldn't Spore that is there a
deeper problem with labor I mean we've
had three female prime ministers they've
all been Tories yeah you know I've I've
asked Rachel Reeves about this before
and and she will say that there is still
a residual problem with leftwing sexism
or what you can call it what you like
theal beer and sandwiches Brigade and
that I think I think there is definitely
within our I think the look there are
some really really great Trade union
leaders are women now okay which there
weren't when I was a journalist there
were none so there you know there are
there has been progress within the Trade
union movement but I think historically
Labor's relations with the Trade union
has given it maybe a more masculine
Macho bent than it maybe should have um
but I think the may I I I I I I'm sure
there will be
um
one for you particularly for you guys um
Eon has produced 21 prime ministers in
our history they were all men by the way
um the labor party's produced six so I
actually think that's a a bigger issue
within our politics I think his class as
much as sex so we're going to do one
more round of questions um got lot
questions up there's a couple there's a
couple of people right at the back there
who have their hands up very that's
definitely the brexit guy you think are
you the brexit GU I've got the ear my
ear is can we do is there there two of
you there that have
questions yeah okay uh no he was raising
his hand so we get increased probability
of getting picked anyway uh so during
rishy Sun's term uh inflation is more
than halfed there has been legislation
that's come in to reduce uh illegal
immigration and as well as uh
on well to be uh decided if there's
going to be economic growth and reduce
debt and my question for you is you
spoke a lot on what uh you saw a lot of
visions that K sto could uh better uh
Britain but you didn't
mention uh what he would actually do so
could you evaluate a bit more on
that uh well I'm not the I I'm not a
member of the lab
party Jeremy kick me out um I think no I
think look what what I would I said
earlier I think he's got his five
missions I think that the the manifesto
is going to be built around them and I
think what he's deliberately doing is
using them as strategic pillars if you
like which come the manifesto will be
set out with detailed policy and
actually I think what he's done quite
cleverly this goes back to joshu's point
of P he got a I think he's a different
sort of politician I've been screaming
week after week you know when's the big
stuff going to come that we're going to
know about and I do think it's still to
come um is that is that I mean you've
studied a lot of electoral Cycles are
they leaving a little late in the day or
I mean it's normal not to reveal too
much policy I feel they are but at the
same time I think we're in a very very
different world to the one that we were
and I think that what what you do when
you have a when you have a sense of a
kind of quite a blank canvas
is that with this mood that is saying
you know oh well labor are going to win
anyway which as I said I don't subscribe
to necessarily but it means that if and
when they are coming out with stuff
there's going to be an awful lot of
interest in it they're not going to want
for attention whereas actually what is
often the case for the opposition is
you're really struggling to get
attention yeah we'd all be thrilled to
see some policy I think very exciting um
I think we'll do one more question go on
then um some there's a a chap right at
the front here let's go there there's a
microphone
coming
noar you got the online people can you
hear me now yeah um distasteful though
it may be is there a case for um
tactical
voting is there a case for tactical
voting I don't think it's distasteful at
all um now one of the one of the
advantages of having been kicked out the
labor party is that I think it's still a
breach of the rule of the labor party
membership to say that you should vote
for another party right but I've got to
say if I lived in a constituency where
the lib Dems were 1500 behind the Tories
and labor were a distant third I would
have no hesitation
whatsoever so um I don't see that as
distasteful at all I think that look we
talk about the electoral
system I actually do think that the
driving Narrative of this coming
election there's always a big question
right and I think the I think the
driving Narrative of this question is
can this country really take another
term of this government and if you're
answer that is no you vote for whatever
you think helps you there if you think
that it is then fine you vote Tor and
you know let your kids pick up the
pieces
afterwards all right um I will remind
you that Alison's book is just come out
in paper back and it is on sale
somewhere at the back so please do pick
up a copy if you haven't got one already
I shall wander up the back he will be
signing um books there I just want to
say thank you very much to intelligence
squ for having us and thank you for
alist to alist for a very interesting
entertaining evening thank
you thank
you
that